so the first screening for Captain
Marvel has been shown and as expected
people are talking about what they saw
including the post-credits scene what's
up everyone it's Warren and major
spoiler alert right now if you do not
want to know about the post-credits
scene for Captain Marvel click away now
alright if you're still here we're going
to talk about the Captain Marvel
post-credit scene because it links
directly to avengers endgame just a
disclaimer i was not there at the
screening but i've seen this all over
the internet and this is coming from we
got this covered calm along with many
other websites and as i mentioned they
have just screened it so people have
seen it so this is coming directly from
those people there are two post-credit
scenes but the first one is the
important one that links Captain Marvel
to Avengers endgame the first one
reportedly features Captain America and
Black Widow back at the avengers base
after the events of Avengers infinity
war with Nick Fury's pager Captain
America and Black Widow are unsure of
what the devices and are unsure of what
to do with it but then Captain Marvel
herself appears behind them and asked
where Fury is and that's the
post-credits scene so based off of this
post-credit scene it seems like the
avengers are going to find Nick Fury's
pager before Captain Marvel does they
may find this with the help of agent
Klein who Nick Fury is talking about in
the post-credits scene of Avengers
infinity war Klein is somebody that Nick
Fury completely trusts and is said to
have a pretty decent role in Avengers in
game but another thing that this tells
us is that obviously Captain Marvel can
track the pager because she shows up at
the Avengers facility which of course
like I just said is where the pager is
and the second post-credit scene is
goosed the cat who of course is an alien
coughing up the tesseract which of
course is the space stone so those are
the two post-credit scenes for Captain
Marvel obviously the first one ties
Captain Marvel into Avengers endgame
which was very expected and with that we
see Captain Marvel interact with the
Avengers for the very first time I don't
want to dive too much into it in case I
end up spoiling something about Avengers
in game but obviously Captain Marvel
will help the Avengers in the movie and
the second post-credit scene shows us
that shield still does have the
tesseract at the end of the movie so let
me know what you think about this
Nexen to Avengers in-game and let me
know what you think is going to happen
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below and don't forget
about my giveaway giving away five imax
tickets if you'd like to interfere your
chance to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like the video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof
[Music]
you